I was sent the script for the
kindergarten teacher and a you know a
pretty conventional way you know they
they just approached me about it and I
had a sort of a rare reaction I've had
it before but we're we're really
contained inside the script was I think
the possibility of telling a really
complicated interesting story sometimes
you know I'll I'll be approached about
something and it won't be in the script
it'll be sort of partially in the script
but oh you know Robert Duvall and Jeff
Bridges are in it or you know whatever
it is in this case I didn't know Sarah
Colangelo at the time but she had
written something which I just knew when
I finished it I was like I need to do
this I have a lot of thoughts about
preparation
you know I it shifts and it's changed a
lot as I've as I've changed and shifted
you know I think I think there came a
time when I was maybe like 35 36 and a
few years ago where I really understood
how to work I would just break down a
scene into what is the event of the
scene and what do I need and what are my
obstacles you know kind of classic way
of looking at scene and in order to
answer the questions I would I don't
know I kind of used like a like a dreamy
almost a kind of unconscious part of my
mind in terms of thinking about yeah how
to break the scene down and then once I
would get on set I would have some kind
of point of view about what I wanted to
seem to be but I would hopefully usually
just let it go and see where it took me
but I would be able to know okay you
know I even though the scene is written
this way and these are the lines and it
isn't explicit I think this scene is an
apology for example and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna play it that way and even though
I'm saying these words to you I'm gonna
be apologizing you know for example and
then lately I've been like throwing it
away even more it's not that I don't
believe in work and doing the technical
work I do and I think it's really served
me and
I think since I've started really taking
that seriously my work has vastly
improved but I'm also now kind of toying
with like I don't know I don't know how
to like really put my finger on it like
just sort of going at it all from a sort
of Trippier place like more like a
dreamier place a more kind of
unconscious place just opening my mind
my my heart to the ideas that I think
are in the piece and seeing what ends up
bubbling up as well as doing the other
work I think but I think mostly with the
kindergarten teacher I don't think I
knew that this is what I was doing at
the time I don't know what I was doing I
was doing the like just open myself up
to the project kind of thing I was just
very difficult to describe but I think
what I was doing was getting in touch
with the part of myself that can that I
think many women are are getting in
touch with right now the part of myself
that was like there's a cost and there's
a consequence to having twisted myself
into pretzels and bent over backwards to
fit myself into the culture that we live
in as a woman and yeah getting in touch
in some way with what that cost is
because that's what I really think the
kindergarten teacher is about there are
some very simple things that you just
have to do almost directorial II our
movie hinges on the audience having to
decide for themselves at each moment
whether they understand and empathize
with her or are repelled by her and it's
got a shift and change all the way
through the movie I mean to the very
last moment and so I mean there's some
things you just you just know you have
to think through like in order for that
to work the movie has to start with her
being warm curious friendly really great
kindergarten teacher you know there's a
way to play it I guess where she's like
a dark sad shadow and there's maybe
that's even a more conventional way
to read the script and begin it I think
that would have alienated everybody I
think she has to be somebody who could
be your friend it could be my friend you
know
so that's that's one thing in terms of
acting with the little boy parker who
plays Jimmy you know I have a lot of
strong feelings about this I I don't
personally believe that a five-year-old
is an actor I just don't think it's
possible and I don't think it's fair to
ask them to do it and we have this weird
job where five-year-olds have to come to
work and I have a five I had if I wrote
the time I was six year old now but I
had a child exactly the same age as
Parker so I was really in touch with I
mean how truly vulnerable a
five-year-old is and I mean it's hard to
remember it's hard I don't remember now
cuz I have a six-year-old you know I
mean it's like but it's extreme and it's
it's something that's very different
than a grown-up and so there was in fact
a moment where even though I was so
deeply compelled by the script and the
ideas in it I almost didn't do it
because I thought how we can protect him
I don't want this child for one minute
to feel that his boundaries are crossed
in the way that the characters
boundaries are crossed and yet you know
the movie was made by a group of mothers
of small children I mean all of us Sarah
me the producers we all were really in
touch with that and so basically it was
very important to me I just thought
anyway even if it hadn't been like sort
of upsetting well not sort of an
upsetting story which it is I still
think the only way to work with a child
that age is super technically you cannot
ask him like you know can you go a
little deeper into the pain in your
heart I mean like five girls never even
understand us so we just it was more
like stand here and when I clap my hands
turn around and look at this X on the
wall or even you know no X on the wall
just Parker you know turns around and
looks at you and then say I don't want
to go you know and he turned around and
say
I don't want to go and we'd think nono
sing it like a song I don't want to go I
don't want to go you know and like just
imitate us just like a song and we had
we got this like um shorthand with him
where we would sing it and he would sing
it back to us and well I think he's so
bright I think what's so wonderful about
Parker is that he isn't performing
himself in the way that we all end up
doing and it's shocking to see how early
little kids even started to do it he's
not and he's really bright and smart but
I will say that it's Sarah who put
together that performance because if we
had done it any other way
we would have been compromising him and
we didn't compromise him I'm proud of a
lot of things I really am proud of it I
love sitting and I've seen the movie
twice all the way through with an
audience and then I've seen the end like
the sort of last sequence many times
because we've been doing a lot of q and
a's afterwards and i've never been
involved with a movie where the audience
is so vocal where they laugh and gasp
and like almost moan as they're watching
the movie at first I found that really
difficult to be honest and especially
the laughter there was a part at
Sundance the first time I saw it where
it really felt as if it as if the
audience was laughing at her and I think
they were laughing at her and of course
I relate so deeply to her even though
obviously I note you know she's so
flawed but and I think well what was so
what's so cool about it is they were
laughing at her because they had been so
allied with her and then she really
disturbed them and I think the laughter
in some ways was like I had nothing to
do with this I was never on her side
I like this woman is nothing like me and
then what's so amazing is right after
that moment you have to be alone with
her weeping in a bathroom and feels the
effect of your laughter on a really real
human
so I don't know I guess I'm very proud
of the of the effect it has and also i'm
proud that you know you can like it or
not like it you can empathize with her
or not empathize with her
you can emphasize with her up till this
point and not after you can go with her
on and off all throughout the movie but
i can say that i know that what we're
offering is something truthful and then
the opportunity to decide for yourself
where you come out on it and i think
especially in america where we're just
we're being lied to all the time and
both sides agree on that
you know the far right says all the
media is lies and the left says the
president is lying to you
i think we're a little bit inured to it
and i think people are hungry for
something truthful and for the
opportunity to like come up with their
own position after being offered
something truthful which is what the
movie does so i feel proud of that i
guess it's always gonna be it's gonna
weaken you and your work to try to fit
yourself into some idea of what you
think other people think you're supposed
to be i mean of course we all do that
and and it weakens our work you know but
the strongest work i think comes from
being finding a confidence and finding
the vulnerability to let who you
actually are into your work and I
actually think vanity which of course we
all have family you know so I'm not late
to all of this can be really problematic
in terms of them in terms of work and I
sometimes they see actors it's like it's
like we all respond to what's human we
also respond to beauty of course but we
really I do anyway I see someone whose
body looks real whose face looks real
whose makeup there's a little messed up
or has some wrinkles you know and I
recognize Humanity in it and the work is
stronger so I think to try to erase all
of those things which
you know I guess in some ways considered
flaws I think really does also weaken
the work but the other thing I would say
this is just like this is more of an
acting thing than like a life thing but
I find if I'm ever just only meaning the
literal meaning of the words I'm like
bored and it's not that good what I I
think makes work that I like to watch of
my own and and of other people's is when
you have some other motive you are
saying the words and you mean them but
there's at least one other thing going
on that you're trying to communicate to
the other person you're working with or
that that that is that is important in
the scene and if it's letter if it's
just literal I'm always in trouble
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]